た
[音楽]
[拍手]
あの4ヶ月ぐらい2分イベントを使われて昨日夜
4時くらい朝悪事改革を愛してもまだ教えてずっと上の古代の館でスピーカー皆さんは
このシアター水すごい一定女性チョイスは c なりして
東海の皆さまはこの大雨になるわざと怒られて
であそこので党バーチ10分で終わろうしてこれ0
できたらもっと大きい箸でこれは始まりたいなと思ってい
新婚医者さんのレースのスピーチをしているかもしれないですけど
あのスペーシア g 3は貧困者さんただけじゃなくて会社の皆さんの
者だったからってい
今日は東京から味の朝6時の氷結して
最高のスピードしたいなぁと思ってるんで人もしよかったら
今回利用するで大きいよろしくお願いします
[拍手]
それでは御関数が満足するまで何回も視聴有難う御座いいただきます
はいさていよいよとされ持つ e カードになりました
大きいのして歓迎西葛西祖母は量産ですお願いしまーす
ありません
いや俺めちゃくちゃ今 g せすげーなーシーンですよ
やりたいことができて少し7実績がでついて
本当にめちゃくちゃの好きなことをしやがる
人生を送れています
楽しいしまうしかというと楽しくなると言うじゃないですか今日
スピーチをしてこの幸せな環境皆さん少し遅紫陽花難に陥っています
ちょっと旅しましょうかさせてください
自分1997年は0東京育ち
思シティーボーイですね c 5位で終わりませんであの特徴あると楽観し不当
ブービー駐車場にある潮
we are ぬーっは
大丈夫かなとは書いたんですよさっ相当すごいなっちゃったっていう
そうあのこれすごい怒られたんですよ
3くらい投資要請に合わせ待っています
で
今ぶち上げたタイプで歯医者をやってい
今従軍し70名くらいや愚直 pos ような足を言ってるんですけど今までもめちゃ
くさー
事業を潰してしていろんな定義がしました
今まで僕はどれしてしてやっと数字て根が真面目ないっ
15歳というか企業を始めたんですね
その時に流れたかというと
息さえない言われなんです
多くの方は多分そういう看板ですってまあやんとマジ頭を上げなんですよ
お味あたりとか話に沿ったですじゃないですか
でやっとで言って王道の導きなさいって言われたりとか
そろそろてくださ
でも随分経って全く意識沿いそうじゃなくて
士官が足りないなん
思います
自分には夢があります
日本発の世界を代表する経営者になるって言うよりがあります
でめちゃくちゃに音がするんですよ
30年前にも
世界時価総額ランキングトップ50話31歳なんです
日本の企業って
今って豊田市内んですよ
そんぐらい今日本ってすごい6世界
昔は d の西端に今落ち込んでしまっていうところがあって
viron 素晴らしいじゃないですか
日本人なピザ屋さんたりとか技術のソーサーたりとかそういうことって絶対に世界負け
ない環境は日本にもありません
だからこそ自分は思わず世界キーを目指して今
応用しています
言えともう一個志があります
今日は世界中の人々は幸せそうに生きてる世界を作りたいなというふうに思っています
イベント志してすん茶色に見えて全然違うものなんですけど
夢っていうのは自己実現自分がこうなりたいんだという思いから生まれるものを志して
はみんなの夢が集まって
でシャーンだーっ思っていて
この志世界中の人が
毎日さん須藤にイギリスから作っていて
エアーそんなやないというソーター部平米だねこれ
みんなおいしい見えないですかこういう志高い人になるというのはリーダーシップだ
なぁと思っていてどんどん志高いするだろうというふうに指
行動します
今自分に12なんですけどなんでそんなに志高くなってるんですかっていうふうに
たまにはれたですよね
でそれってあの自分からしたらそんな中に先行レーションってから妥当じゃなくて
色んな人と会ったりとか
こういう杉田迫ったりとかしていく中で少しずつ
ちさっても技かなって思っていて
これ明日の高さところなんですよ10最初日本書紀を作るな
あの単発のバイトサービスを待っていて働くイーグルを作っ
で本当にそれ右側で困ってる e shop 店とかホテルとかで端時間場所を模って
ちょっと
はい与えてばそういうことで従業員さん下げるって言うサーブされてるんですよ
それを先生ないと上で当たる25を作るんだってちゃったんですね
中山やおら4回注意4するんだ you いていて
世界で動画でカードがあって覚え方があります
そうするとどうなるかっていうと日本一をしてから日で伊達式と世界一してを減らして
ゆけして全然違うんです
どれか1頑張って言うと本当に毎日姫はこういう買われがちなんですよ
例えば世界を減らすと英語の勉強記者しないし世界の自分と脚住むでは何シャール
なっちあげたりするんですね
日本になるシミやといいじゃないですか本当所を見始めたりするとすごい話山
一緒に滑るそうすると家からどんどん誘ってすごい充実さ生活を子がずれなんていう
ふうに思っています
なのでどうやっなるぞ
どうやってしたを託していくカードと紙魚子
考えながら行動することはすごい大事になってくるんじゃないかなというふうに思って
います
今日は時間を選ばないするっていうところでお話させてもらってるのでもう一個
違うクリックしたら自分について話したいなというふうに思います
24秒に1人がこれ何が早いと思います
実は交通事故で亡くなっているんです
uho 世界の情報で実際で0なんですけど
24秒1位はまあやっちゃうして敷いた場合もありますし
パウダーで死んでしまう場合は
今回ノイズが死んでいて自分が話して最新の統計上はアンディも裸足でしまって
るっていう
ロイなってですね
何かいるかと言うと自分たちからこの後ペットを渡って帰ると重視れたんじゃないん
ですよ
0パーでないんス絶対
た時に本当に今日
思い切りいきますかっていうところで
is c でもいいよ移住
明日しでも今回に贅沢できるこのば御社が行かれたんですよ
すごい雷につい
やっぱりこう
ループなってしまうとまぁじゃないですかだからあの
今まで行っていることがそう言っていくぞよせーなーと思ってもらっ
するけどでもいやそれでも写真たらすごいな公開それではまたっ
そういうところをなくしてって得ず c ためいいように全部できるってすごい大事か
なと
もう一個自分でこの子とお祝いて知恵時に胸を張って生きるってことをすごい意識して
報道しています
いこ自体があって自分ずっと中古サッパいるたんですよ
あのー紀子新版では変わって素描行きなさいとれて様行ったんですけど
心臓の弁がちょっと生じゃんけんをしてなかったね
で心拍数が45中なんですよ1分間で2児の母だって60以上なんですけどあそこれ
体中に血液を皆さん凄い難しい字
アップ今も買わないんですけどそういう時サッカー競ってねそう賛成
心臓を入れちゃうワケスポーツだから主治医からは絶対やらん
あの寿命1月するぞ入られたんです
それすごい悩んですごい強くなってみられなったんですけど
決断サークルやなっと
あって今更後悔は全くしない何もしないです
ところで公開しないんですけど言われればから自分の引き合いサッカー
んです
ブーブーすごいだろ沿いパーティーロス5位池田薄黒ストアって
すごい楽しそうだねって言われたりするんですけどそういうふうな
以下ば自分のやりたいのみスポットん貫くということが
a 取り重と二重にならないんじゃないかなというふうに思います
ブーブん
archi 以下あっ大きいちゃんって言っあああああいいよパクッにょ
そういうな否定形ですね
でおじさんがれてすごい裕福なさで生まれてそうしたんですよ
a m そうにっ
あの頃に
キラ梵しまして ot をを結んでアド近く作用た時にボッチャを伝えよう
おいますよねいう綺麗なんですけど
向こうが倒産してしまってう死亡させたと言う
真籠ん
が眠そういう子の方がありまして
おじいちゃん本当にこういうなんかデバイスはいすごいしんどいとでなって
幽霊入った2をして座から働いて着車庫苦労しデー
今自分がどんな楽しそうに働ける
を注ぎマースなことができるような中でを築いてきたのはおじいさんでした
その爺ちゃんば18歳時に
まあと全身でしまって最後死ぬ間際にちゃんと間だってわかったんですけど親父さんの
話した時に
昔の顔っての話すごいさん降誕祭してくれるんですよ
呵責そんなたんだぞ俺自らたしたしていればいい
パラジウムは
をがくぽないって言う
愛車をスタン作って次世代にもずっと続いていく
最初にもはず世界起業するたいなというふうに
本当に誓って言う間だなぁと思っていて
今22デーもしかしたら93の利益があることじゃ客様減弱安心だろう感ないですよ
自分本当にじゃない思っていて中学生命医し高校生名ショタの方も今日いらっしゃると
思うんですけどこれが時間を
愛を目指して
どういう下へ
過ごしていくかを考える機会になっているのはそういう嬉しいなというふうに思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]